hello everyone and welcome back to the
exciting tournament dos Hermanas 1996
where we have a game from round three
Miguel lcas Cordova the local Spanish
player versus vishan Anand and even
though it was a top 10 tournament Miguel
at the time was rated number 29 in the
world but uh he was incredibly strong
and also lost uh well we could say the
least amount of games here only one game
that he lost and he was pretty much
known for that he was incredibly solid
and incredibly hard to beat uh he was uh
three times second for a world CH
championship match to Vladimir kramnik
even in his world CH championship match
against Gary Kasparov in 2000 uh you
know that kramnik was Victorious without
losing a single game then later on in
2004 he was a second kik's match against
Leo and then in 2006 the the you know
reunification match with vesselin
topalov and um yeah you you'll see the
game and you'll see how uh how
incredibly difficult it is to calculate
these lines like some of the lines I I I
couldn't understand even with with the
engine but I will make it a nice pause
the video moment for you at also uh you
know enjoy the position to their fullest
and also interestingly this was played
in 1996 uh Miguel Cordoba was also a
computer scientist and uh he was
appointed in 1997 to be one of the team
uh that uh one of the members of the
team that prepared IBM's deep blue for
their match against Gary Kasparov and
well you know the out of that match it
was the first time ever in chess history
that a computer was Victorious over a
human professional in in a chess match
um or especially over a world champion
in a chess match uh so yeah he he
definitely doesn't like to lose and he
is very very solid regardless of of the
the project he's currently in so let's
check it out Miguel has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn with Knight to F3
he goes for the ready opening uh in
round two
Anan faced Kasparov and it is a draw in
only 25 moves but it involves peace
sacrifices Queen sacrifices so if you
guys want I can even show that one I
mean it is very nice even though it's a
draw but okay Knight to F6 we have C4 uh
Pawn to C5 and on goinging symmetrical
we have Pawn to G3 and Knight to C6 so
the uh symmetrical variation of the
English uh Bishop to G2 we have Pawn to
G6 and now castles and Here pawn to D6
so like you would play a against si you
know likeing playing a sicilian against
E4 only E4 and D4 have not been played
so Knight to C3 we have Bishop to G7 and
now Pawn to A3 preparing Pawn to B4 so
castles and The Rook to B1 and the
position is still reached uh fairly
often nowadays and people play A5 here
to stop Pawn to B4 uh but uh a different
uh idea was used here un plays Pawn to
D5 first he strikes in the center C
captures Knight captures and now Knight
to G5 again Knight captures and D5 is
the more common move here but Knight G5
uh sh Shifting the Knight over to E4 and
you do have to do something about the
Knight on D5 now being attacked twice so
Pawn to E6 Knight G to E4 and now Pawn
to B6 defending on C5 and also preparing
to develop the light Square Bishop uh
Pawn to D3 and now uh Pawn to H6
stopping the development of the bishop
to G5 uh we have Bishop to D2 now and
Bishop to B7 nicely countering the light
Square Bishop on G2 Knight captures on
D5 we have e captures on D5 and now
Knight back to C3 again with a double
attack on the D5 pawn pawn to D4 and
here we have Knight to D5 there is a
game uh that was played um where Knight
to A4 was used but that's a that's a
pretty bad move and it was played some
six years before this game uh but here
we have Knight to D5 by Miguel and it is
the strongest move recommended by the
engine and also as of move 16 we have a
completely new game never again to be
reached so okay let's see this Rook to
B8 Anan shifts The Rook over from this
diagonal also to help out with the
defense of the bishop uh Pawn to B4
strongest uh in any position and also in
this one and now Anand doesn't capture
with the c Pawn but rather he captures
with the Knight and unleashes a double
or rather a triple attack on the Knight
on D5 and if you uh capture on B4 then C
captures on B4 also with the exchange of
light Square Bishop so instead Knight
captures on B4 with played uh we have C
captures and B for a captures and Anand
also trades Bishops captures captures
and goes Rook to E8 stopping the
advancement of the E Pawn as long as the
pawn is stuck on E2 it is a long-term
Target so here King back to G1 it's hard
to say if it's necessary to play this
move uh uh you know I I I did allow the
engine to Crunch the numbers here just
to see how how precise King to G1 was
it's not the engine's first choice but
it does say that it's okay to play it
and if you're a human of course you
always play this especially with the
black queen having access to D5 you do
not want to check every move if the
queen can connect to something so
sometimes you have to do that but here
just King to G1 we have Rook to C8
getting the Rook to the open C file and
Rook to E1 now again maybe e e E4 E3 can
be played but Anan just plays Rook to C6
and uh yeah you can play it but uh let's
say Pawn to E4 and after d captures on
E3 what do you play you can't really uh
play with the pawn uh capture with the
pawn because Queen captures and D3 have
to play either Bishop captures or Rook
captures and then you're stuck with the
isolated D Pawn which will be a
long-term weakness so after Rook C6
Queen to A4 going after the A7 pawn and
allowing Anan to double up on the E file
and go after the E2 Pawn so that's
exactly what Anan does Rook to E6 we
have Queen captures on A7 and Rook
captures on E2 uh we have a rook trade
Rook captures on E2 Rook captures on E2
and now you have to do something about
the bishop hanging here so Bishop to F4
and Anand plays a most uh spectacular
move here the the only piece defending
the B6 Pawn is the queen and Anand plays
Queen to D5 not only moving the queen
from the back rank but also sacrificing
the B6 pawn and this is now uh I think
the the most interesting position in the
entire game because the question is can
the B6 Pawn be captured if yes why so
and if not why why not so uh so it was
not captured in the game but I just want
to show you what happens if Queen
captures on B6 do you see what um uh do
you see what Anand had in mind
sacrificing the B6 Pawn feel free to
pause the video and try to try to win
this game with black while I give you a
couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it uh I mean you probably uh
if you are not a grandmas you definitely
should uh you know take up chess
seriously and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Pawn G
G5 uh yes looks like an odd move and
probably the move you found was Rook
captures on F2 followed by King captures
and queen to A2 check but it doesn't
work unless you play G5 point is that if
you go Rook captures on F2 King captures
on F2 Queen to A2 check there's this
super annoying Bishop to d2 move that's
I mean is disgusting and now if the
queen captures it you're just going to
move the king and there's no way to
connect with the Rook on B1 anymore
white will just be up the exchange and
all in all it's a draw uh so so that's
that's not the way to do it but if after
this um Queen captures on B6 move you
play Pawn to G5 first uh you no longer
allow such moves to exist now the bishop
cannot go to E3 the bishop cannot go to
D2 and of course if you go Bishop to C1
then The Rook no longer controls D1
square and it's Rook to E1 Checkmate so
what would happen after G5 is that
Bishop will have to be put somewhere
like D6 also maybe I don't know for some
reason there's no better square and now
only now you will play Rook captures on
F2 and after of course mate is being
threatened so you have to capture the
rook and now Queen to A2 with check you
will win the Rook back and after the
king moves uh anywhere doesn't really
matter Queen captures and B1 and yes you
could give a check here for example King
H7 and now even try to defend the pawn
but you cannot If you defend the pawn
with um King E2 we just give a check and
then eliminate the pawn since the king
cannot go to E3 and if you go to King to
E4 to defend the pawn it's even worse as
it's a forc ma in six Queen H1 check
only Square King to F5 you're going to
play Queen to F3 with check Bishop to F4
only move and now Queen captures on D3
you're not even interested in the bishop
King to G4 F5 check and after King H5
Queen to D1 check G4 and queen captures
on G4 will be Checkmate so H this is
what Anan found after this queen to D5
move so not captures and Rook captures
an F2 right away but captures uh Pawn to
G5 and only then Rook captures an F2
followed by que to A2 I mean yes I know
if any of you found
this you you are a a better better
player Than Me by far uh so Rook to A1
was played not tricking Miguel as you
know he he wasn't the hardest player to
beat at this event for for for no reason
uh and now Anan plays of course now the
same trick no longer works as there's no
way to connect with the Rook Anan plays
Queen to B5 he goes after the D3 pawn
queen to A8 with check King to H sorry
not King to H7 un retreated The Rook
Rook to E8 he attacked the queen now
Queen to A3 defending the B4 pawn and
now Bishop to f8 putting pressure on the
B4 pawn and now look at this Pawn to H4
just giving up the B4 Pawn but it
doesn't really do all that much for
Anand if he captures the pawn then Queen
B3 preparing to pile up on the bishop
here and once the queen moves you're
going to play Rook The Rook A7 put
pressure on F7 and there's just not
enough time to organize an attack
against the white king with F7 Pawn
being so vulnerable You're going to have
to either move the queen or move the
rook and then white has all the time in
the world the organized counter play so
instead after Pawn to H4 uh now Anan
finds it and if you found it uh in the
line where I ask you to pause the video
now you will find it definitely and that
is Pawn to G5 now especially with the
queen also guarding G5 so H captures H
captures and now again what do you do
with the bishop you can go Bishop to E3
you can go Bishop to C1 so Bishop to D2
but now Rook to E2 again with Tempo uh
Bishop to E1 as you will need defense
for the F2 pawn and now Queen to F5 it's
a this is a very interesting position
because after Queen to F5 anan's
position is much better but it's not
winning uh you know in a few moves with
Queen to D5 uh arand missed this idea
Rook to E6 Rook to H6 and Rook to H1 is
Unstoppable and by Unstoppable I mean
white will have to ruin his position
with something like paon f three and
then it's going to be much much easier
to win this but okay un unplayed Queen
to F5 and now we have Queen to A8 fig
figuring out the defense here also you
control this diagonal uh now comes Queen
captures on D3 and queen to d8 now so
what do you play here you have to keep
an eye on your D Pawn H but not uh not
right away I plays Queen to F3 and now
uh here Miguel can capture on D4 and he
can capture on G5 with check now G 5
capturing with check is nice but also if
you can eliminate the D4 Pawn that would
be even nicer the problem is if you play
Queen captures on D4 Bishop to G7 now
secures the queen and after Queen to d8
check King to H7 uh there's no way to
actually stop Bishop to C3 uh okay your
Rook is hanging but even if you move the
Rook um and of course the queen is
covering the A3 and C3 squares so
there's no stopping this even if Rook C1
Bishop to C3 just wins and that's all
there is so after Queen f three Miguel
played Queen captures and G5 with check
Bishop to G7 and now Queen back to d8
with check uh King to H7 and now uh of
course Queen to H4 with check King to G6
and now Queen to F4 and the reason why
this um series of checks is bad if if we
go back a few moves before he started
giving all the checks okay you capture
on G5 Bishop to G7 and now you play
Queen to F4 uh much much different you
can go into the end game and the end
game is objectively a draw but for some
reason uh Miguel although he played a
you know IM Immaculate game up to this
point he gave a few checks Queen check
King H7 Queen H4 check King G6 and now
he played Queen T4 offering a queen
trade there's just no good explanation
why you would do this you could go into
an end game it's the exact same end game
when you you could have Anan King on G8
but no you allow anan's King to improve
the position by by going to G6 and now
you offer a queen trade with anan's King
so active so I don't have a good
explanation of why he did this could be
time
trouble or maybe he thought he had
something other than offering a queen
trade here H because the king is on G6
the problem is he just doesn't so he
just captures here Queen captures on F4
and Anan should capture of course the
end game is now winning for him Pawn to
D3 and yes you can go Rook to D1 but
King to F5 you cannot capture as the
bishop on D1 is hanging on E1 so he has
to defend it but now King to E4 the
black king is uh you know very much in
time to guard the pass de on which would
not be possible if your king started on
G8 and okay we have Pawn to B5 here uh
the the pawn will not be uh the bishop
will not be able to attack the pawn on a
light square but the king and the Rook
most certainly will so here Bishop to D4
putting pressure on F2 now comes Rook to
B1 and Rook to A2 preparing to trade off
the Rooks with Rook to A1 as unand
calculates the bishop end game is very
much winning for him so Rook to D1 now
comes comes Rook to A1 and we have a
trade captures captures and now King to
D4 interestingly you could also play
King to uh after sorry Bishop to D was
Bishop to D2 was played and now King to
D4 an and plays U you know a funny move
here even though King to F3 is perfectly
fine because you're preparing Bishop to
D4 and even if Bishop to E1 you're still
going to play Bishop to D4 whatever
white plays pretty much F5 is the only
move you will capture on F2 and that's
it if Bishop captures D2 wins the game
this is covered this is covered the
white king can not Advance closer to the
D Pawn but Anand found an even funnier
line he played King to D4 allowing his
King to be skewed here and I mean
there's nothing better Bishop to E3
check was played King to C3 Bishop
captures on B6 was played and now King
to C2 even uh you could play D2 right
away this check doesn't really save
white but he played King to C2 and he
was in this position and move 49 that
Miguel ilas Cordova resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
the problem is uh
whether you defend the the square this
way doesn't really matter just Bishop to
C3 and the pawn marches forward or if
you the you know try this way Bishop to
E3 not much better just Bishop to D4
also you stop the advancement of the
pawn and now if King T1 you will just
trade captures captures D2 check and of
course you get a queen into the game and
win so very very uh hardfought game very
interesting moves by both both Miguel
and vishwanathan but in the end Anand
was Victorious with the black pieces and
Anand is the only player to defeat
Miguel in this tournament and uh with
the black pieces um even uh and uh yeah
he finished uh I believe in the uh I
don't have the standings now for some
reason they they uh are removed but yeah
only game that he lost was tanatan Anand
then he was uh on four and a half points
which was very very strong uh so yeah
very nicely done by Miguel but Anand
takes this one and uh
uh yeah I mean it was a really really
close close tournament if you guys
remember from the standings Anand and
Kasparov only finishing half a point
behind topalov and kramnik uh so yeah
that's the game I really hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by the by
the one of the people behind IBM's uh by
you know behind the training of IBM's de
blue I mean uh probably uh some secrets
were deeply implemented into ibmd blue
if if you was able to take down Kasparov
at the time as you know if you guys
remember there were some talks of you
know uh deep blue not making computer
moves that it actually made some human
moves but you know what are you going to
do uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Welsh fan Sasha vidler Mark Henley
Brennan Michael mes and Frank Banner for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
wanton that game between anad and
Kasparov uh you know say something in
the comments see you soon